HAPPENING THERE RIGHT NOW.
>> Bill: ISSUES GALOR.
ONE BORDER TOWN.
25% OF MIGRANTS DROPPED OFF AT
A SHELTER TESTED POSITIVE FOR
COVID.
THE DIRECTOR SAYS IT WAS JUST
IN THE FIRST GROUP DROPPED OFF.
THE ACTUAL NUMBER MAY GO HIGHER
HAPPENING IN HARLINGEN, TEXAS.
THE MAYOR, CHRIS BOSWELL.
WHITE HOUSE DOESN’T SAY IT’S A
CRISIS.
THEY’RE ASKING FOR VOLUNTEERS
TO HELP.
IF IT’S NOT A CRISIS, WHY DO
YOU NEED VOLUNTEERS AND HOW
WOULD YOU CHARACTERIZE IT,
MAYOR?
>> GOOD MORNING, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME ON.
CERTAINLY CAN TURN INTO A
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
WE’VE SEEN THIS BEFORE A FEW
YEARS AGO.
WHEN THE UNACCOMPANIED MINORS
IN PARTICULAR COME TO OUR
COMMUNITIES, THEY DON’T HAVE
ANYPLACE TO GO.
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE SHELTERS THAT
HAVE BEEN OPERATING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES, INCLUDING
HARLINGEN FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS.
TRADITIONAL SHELTERS OPERATE
WELL AND SAFELY FOR THE
UNACCOMPANIED MINORS.
WHEN THERE IS SUCH AN INFLUX IT
CAN BE A DANGEROUS SITUATION.
>> Dana: WHAT’S THE IMPACT ON
YOUR TOWN?
I THINK LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS THE
ACTUALLY THE HARDEST GOVERNMENT
WHERE YOU ACTUALLY HAVE TO DO
THINGS FOR PEOPLE.
WHAT’S THE IMPACT FOR YOU?
>> WELL, THESE ARE DECISIONS
MADE BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND SHOULD BE HANDLED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BUT THEY
TURN INTO PROBLEMS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS BECAUSE ABOUT THREE
WEEKS AGO THE BORDER PATROL
TOLD US IN McALLEN, BROWNSVILLE
AND HARLINGEN THEY WOULD BE
RELEASING PRIMARILY FAMILIES
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
THEY COME HERE NOT -- THIS IS
NOT THE ENDPOINT.
THIS IS NOT THEIR FINAL
DESTINATION.
THEY’RE BEING RELEASED INTO
BROWNSVILLE, McALLEN AND
HARLINGEN BECAUSE WE HAVE
AIRPORTS AND BUS STATIONS AND
CHARITY FACILITIES.
AND SO WHEN THOSE CHARITY
FACILITIES CAN’T ACCOMMODATE
THEM, THEN WE HAVE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL ACCOMMODATIONS FOR
THEM.
SO WE HAVE -- OUR CITY COUNCIL
HAS OPENED UP ONE OF OUR
FACILITIES, COMMUNITY CENTER,
IN CASE OUR LOCAL CHARITY
LOAVES AND FISHES NEEDS THAT
ADDITIONAL SPACE.
SO THAT BECOMES A BURDEN AND AN
EXPENSE ON THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS REALLY
NEED TO HAVE HELP FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO RESPOND
TO THE RELEASE OF THESE
IMMIGRANTS INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
>> Bill: IT IS MARCH 9th.
DID YOU SEE THIS COMING?
>> WELL, OBVIOUSLY WITH THE
ELECTION THERE WERE THE IDEA
THAT THERE WOULD BE A CHANGE IN
POLICY.
WE KNEW THERE WOULD BE A CHANGE
IN POLICY.
WE ALSO KNEW THERE WERE LARGE
NUMBERS OF IMMIGRANTS CAMPED IN
MEXICO WAITING TO BE -- TO
ENTER THE UNITED STATES TO SEEK
ASYLUM.
SO ONCE THE POLICY CHANGED,
THEN SURE, THEY ARE GOING TO
MOVE ACROSS AND THEN TRY TO
FIND THEIR FINAL DESTINATIONS.
ONE OF THE THINGS ABOUT -- THIS
IS NOT JUST A BORDER ISSUE.
THIS IS AN ISSUE FOR EVERYONE
BECAUSE THESE FOLKS AS I SAID,
THIS IS NOT THEIR FINAL
DESTINATION ALONG THE BORDER.
>> Bill: ONE MORE PRECISE
QUESTION.
JEN PSAKI SAID WE’RE HERE IN
THIS CIRCUMSTANCE BECAUSE WE’RE
HUMANE.
WAS THE LAST ADMINISTRATION
INHUMANE?
>> WELL, MANY OF US BELIEVE
THAT IT IS NOT HUMANE TO HAVE
YOUNG CHILDREN TRAVEL FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA TO THE BORDER
AND THAT IS NOT -- THAT IS
FRAUGHT WITH POTENTIAL PROBLEMS
OF TRAFFICKING AND DIFFICULTIES
IN TRAVELING SO FAR FOR SUCH A
LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
AND I THINK THERE HAS BEEN IN
THE PAST BIPARTISAN CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT BEING A HUMANITARIAN
PROBLEM.
>> Dana: MR. MAYOR, THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH US TODAY